Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Marine Thollot : Pas accordé !
Alexia Basset : Tu crois ?
MT : Ça vous est déjà arrivé,
en échangeant avec quelqu’un,
de vous demander si vous étiez
sur la même longueur d’onde ?
(Violon qu’on accorde)
AB : Pssst ! C’est toi.
Ce n’est pas moi, c’est toi !
MT : Oups !
(Violon qu’on accorde)
AB : Quand on commence une conversation,
on arrive parfois avec ses certitudes.
Et si on ne s’accorde pas,
on a peu de chances de se comprendre.
MT : Gnagnagnagnagna.
(Violon qu’on accorde)
C’est bon.
(Musique de l’Inspecteur Gadget au violon)
AB : On est en récital.
MT : Ben oui.
AB : Le public s’attend
à un répertoire classique.
Et toi, tu nous joues
« Inspecteur Gadget ! »
(Rires)
MT : Mais c’est parce que je l’aime bien.
C’est du classique que tu veux ?
(Musique de l’Inspecteur Gadget au violon)
(Fin de la musique avec un vibrato)
(Rires)(Applaudissements)
Hmm, un peu trop sérieux...
attends, avec douceur.
(L’inspecteur Gadget avec pizzicato)
Ou d’un ton plaintif.
(L’inspecteur Gadget plus lent)
AB : Avec de la légèreté ?
(L’inspecteur Gadget en Allegro)
En colère !
(L’inspecteur Gadget version irritée)
Avec passion.
(L’Inspecteur Gadget Gracioso)
AB : C’est vrai qu’on peut dire
une même phrase de mille façons.
MT : Écoute, on peut aussi
la jouer sans âme.
(L’Inspecteur Gadget)
AB : Oui, enfin là, c’est comme si
on parlait pour ne rien dire.
Il faut un minimum d'intention, un but.
Et comme l’envie de séduire, de plaire.
(Violon : Carmen)
MT : Ouh !
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
AB : Séduction ou défi ?
(La guerre des étoiles)
Shhhhut.
MT : Je suis ton père.
(Rires)
AB : S’exprimer avec des intentions
pour provoquer des réactions.
MT : La peur, par exemple.
(Violon)
(Cris d’effroi)
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
MT : Échec total.
J’ai entendu des rires !
AB : Ça vous fait rire ?
Visiblement, on ne réagit pas tous pareil.
MT : Mais si, parfois c’est limpide,
mais pour un autre résultat.
Attend, j’ai une idée. (Chuchote)
AB : Ah, oui !
J’essaye.
(Violon : I love you baby)
MT : Ah, ben voilà !
Vous souriez ?
Ça marche ?
MT : Waouh, waouh !
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Désolé, je me suis un peu
emballée dans mes idées.
AB : Oui !
On a beau parler le même langage,
ça ne suffit pas pour se comprendre.
(Violon)
parce que, non seulement c’est une part
de nous qui s’exprime,
(Violon)
avec la voix de nos expériences,
de nos apprentissages,
(Violon)
avec notre vocabulaire,
nos codes, notre culture.
(Violon)
Mais pour se comprendre,
il faut rencontrer l’autre
dans son monde, à lui, et l’écouter.
(Violon)
T’en penses quoi, toi ?
(Violon decrescendo)
Comment ?
(Violon pizzicato)
Je n’entends pas bien, parle plus fort !
(Violon)
MT : Rapproche-toi !
C’est peut-être une question de distance,
ou de proximité.
(Violon)
Tu m’entends mieux là ?
AB : Oui, mais je ne suis pas certaine
de mieux comprendre.
MT : Alors, viens avec moi.
(Violon)
(Applaudissements)
MT : C’était plus clair ?
AB : Hmm, mais ce n’est
toujours pas ça, la clé.
MT : Mais de quelle clé tu parles ?
AB : Eh bien, notre communication.
Réussir à se comprendre,
à mettre en commun nos pensées.
MT : C’est vrai, on ne s’écoute pas
toujours bien ; trop loin, trop proche.
Il faut réussir à partager.
AB : La base, c’est déjà
de se synchroniser.
MT : Avec un tempo.
Ensemble : Le même pour tout le monde.
AB : Et puis, il faut aussi
de la sincérité.
MT : Être présent en conscience,
AB : comme avec ce proche
pas revu depuis longtemps,
MT : avec lequel on se reconnecte
en quelques secondes.
AB : On se dit l’essentiel
MT : ou pas.
Les sentiments passent dans les mots,
dans les regards aussi.
MT : Les émotions font vibrer nos âmes,
Ensemble : tout comme
celles de nos violons.
(Violon)
AB : Ce qui rend le langage
de la musique si puissant,
MT : c’est qu’il parle à tout le monde.
AB : Les vibrations nous touchent
sans prévenir.
MT : Parfois, elles nous soignent,
nous transforment ou nous apaisent.
AB : En fait, dans la vie,
Ensemble : nous sommes tous les musiciens
de notre communication.
(Applaudissements)
AB : Alors, si chaque jour,
on prend le temps de s’écouter
MT : vraiment,
AB : d’accorder nos instruments,
MT : d’ajuster nos tempos,
AB : de régler nos volumes,
MT : de jouer sur la même fréquence,
AB : avec l’intention
de nous mettre en lien
MT : et de créer des harmonies sincères
dans nos échanges.
AB : Ça peut nous surprendre,
MT : vous interpeller,
AB : nous motiver,
MT : vous emporter,
AB : nous animer,
MT : vous émouvoir,
AB : nous faire vibrer.
MT : Et ça peut même mettre chacun de nous
Ensemble : en mouvement.
(Violon)
Ensemble : Hey !
(Applaudissements)